only a handful of the world's countries
are unscathed by the coronavirus for the
majority battling the disease there is
no single answer so many are testing out
different measures to fight the disease
Texas tries roadblocks to stop the
spread South Korea has aggressively
tested for the disease Italy has
extended its emergency anti coronavirus
measures with a lockdown of the entire
country most agree keeping people at
home is vital Hong Kong has one of the
best records in fighting the virus just
four deaths in a population of seven and
a half million that's not much smaller
than New York 2003 SARS outbreak lives
long in the memory and the city brought
in tough early measures to get ahead the
end of January Hong Kong close schools
it sent all of its public servants home
the semi-autonomous Chinese territory is
taking no chances on March 19 the Hong
Kong government began enforcing a
compulsory 14-day quarantine for anyone
arriving from overseas arrivals are
instructed to download an app stay home
safe which pairs with an electronic
bracelet so far 65 thousand have been
issued while the product is new the
technology geofencing is actually pretty
old you look at the cross the clothes I
often has a pad on it right if you leave
the shop with the tap on the alarm sound
this is your fencing is - fencing for
the cloths how does your application of
geofencing work in the current crisis
well basically in our apartment we have
different kind of signals your GPS this
signals it can be Wi-Fi signals for
cellular signals Bluetooth signals so
these devices offer a very rich set of
signals unique to the home so just by
learning the signature of where you live
you know whether the person is inside
the place or not like a virtual boundary
yes it's a virtual boundary some people
worry about the privacy implications of
tracking people but but you said that
actually this is privacy preserving to a
certain degree your location it's not
you recorder it's only that you are
inside the home or outside okay so I
started to write inside the government
will be happy camera but not not
checking where you are accepting so when
you go inside right the quarantine place
once you are stepping out into the
government's there have been several
reports of the wristbands failing
despite this it's believed many of Hong
Kong's positive outcomes are due to
conscientious citizens supporting tough
government measures the corona virus has
raised difficult questions about our
freedom and privacy when the health of
our population is at severe risk in Hong
Kong breaking your quarantine could
result in a hefty fine jail time or even
being shipped off to a government
facility
[Music]
you